today I'm going to show you two high
level games by very strong players and
the theme of this lecture I suppose is
how to take advantage of a really poor
opening and take it's a development
advantage in the middle game and how to
take full full full advantage of that
edge it will show you again that even
players that are supposedly at the top
of their career know everything they're
supposed to know about chess can make
mistakes that make you just look and
roll your eyes just at the incredible
decision making but then you see that it
wasn't maybe it wasn't so easy maybe
they missed it because it wasn't that
trivial and the opponent has to have
been a very strong player to take
advantage of it the first game as you
can see from the names of the players
the white player is Polaris which I
think I already on this visit had some
some game and I think I described him as
the eternal number 2 player because he
missed so many chances to play for the
World Championship but he was definitely
up there
his opponent again means no introduction
Mikhail Botvinnik was a very strong
world champion and won maybe one of the
opportunity to be one of the fathers of
chess in Russia and USSR so without
further ado again the opening is
stalling very slowly doesn't seem to be
something dramatic coming out of this
opening but even close defenses have
that tendency to eventually open up and
become very bloody as this one will show
so Quincey - one of the many quiet for
Asians it's a question of taste of
course there's always a conflict on c3
and usually there's some kind of deal
being struck either black will always
give up his defensive bishop he would
really love to have the pitcher but he's
willing to give it up and he's getting
one of two things at a time like in this
game where the Queen comes to c2 in sort
of a developing move after which black
can continue his plan or eventually when
this gets traded there's going to be
double horns and
eternal struggle and to bishops stronger
or the double bonds are stronger here
this question is not asked because like
I said Queen City was played and d5
again many moves are possible in this
position you can cancel quickly
developing you can play the move c5
taking advantage of the fact that the
Queen has just moved from the D file so
you immediately put the question after
which usually white will take and of
course our own move d5 the principle
strike in the center
okay so pawn takes d5 again a very
normal continuation nowadays the
continuation Queen takes on f5 with the
idea of Queen f5 challenging this Queen
has been very very popular the Queen
somehow seems to survive on that square
but again this game was played some 60
years ago 67 years ago so pawn takes
again pretty much normal Bishop g5 yeah
white wants to play III at some point I
don't think he wants to do it with his
bishop locked in so the bishop goes to
the most aggressive square attacking the
knight again black has several choices
but he plays the main line he puts the
question to the bishop immediately he
basically says okay declare your
intentions did you come to take or did
you come to maintain the pin after which
I will pay a small price in compromising
my position but I will chase you to g3
which is maybe for lack of better words
I'll say semi oblivion so if again if
Bishop h4 g5 bishop g3 then maybe 94 can
become a bit annoying right now maybe c5
in Queen a5 very very quickly so he
plays it in first c5 sorry I should
mention also that Bishop takes f6 had
been touched up yet Bishop takes f6
Queen takes f6 III is a very very quiet
line again white gives black to bishops
and he says okay the position is closed
enough to where my Knights are gonna be
worth maybe more you can even play a
three at some moment and force the
bishop to take you can see that the
knight is already hitting on the square
so after Bishop here c5 is being played
and again the question is how to react
to this move what is the best reaction
to this move in the game he plays
believe it or not castlelong
this is I would dare describe it as one
of the more optimistic moves that I have
seen in a very long time and when I say
optimistic is not in a good sense of the
word so what normally happens is again
that something like III can be played
and of course g5 always a good plan
sending the bishop to here Knight e4
with the idea of Queen a5 and blood gets
a very quick development and he tries to
prove that the fact that the White King
is still in the center is going to be a
problem
but I mean let's not take it too
dramatically because white still has
resources it's not like he's lost or
anything he can play rooks e1 and he can
play a three and again it's a struggle
it's just another game yes a question
yeah you could also play Knight f3 here
it wouldn't be tragic I think that the
move that the computer favorite is
actually D takes e5 really considered
because I think the d4 is not really not
much of a threat because probably a
three and at the end of the day I mean I
started by taking a pawn here so d4 is
not really not the move that really
scares me so after they take C v g5
probably again is the most normal
response
followed by 94 again it's a temporary
one sacrifice but I can always regain
the pawn
I will play my Queen to a5 that one is a
goner I'm preferring to put some
pressure along this diagonal but Karis
again remember this guy is one of the
top players may be looking for t1 it
wasn't the top top top but he was
already very strong just to play the
tournament will be held but Finnick is
you know and this is the absolute
Russian championship sabi championship
you cannot you cannot play in that kind
of championship if you weren't really a
very solid Grandmaster but I guess
everybody has a bad day / happy
underestimated the sequence that what
they Nick shows because if you don't
play that then well for sure you have
nothing all of a sudden the night is
unpinned
and there's lots of pressure notice that
the bishop is attacking the knight
that's defending the pawn that's
tagged by the snipe and with the the
exchange of those pawns the rook is
going to participate so offhand I mean
this move is not easy to refute but
watch what Botvinnik did this is really
this is where actually the starting
position for our lecture because this is
already a very early middle game you can
still call it an opening if you want but
at this transition it's really hard to
pinpoint where one ends and one begins
so step one Bishop takes Knight a very
very mature move you think yourself wait
a minute the King just moved away so the
night is not pinned it's true that the
bishop might not look that great but
everything is very weak around the dark
squares are you sure you want to give me
the bishop for the knight and the answer
is yes and that's a very strong answer I
think that if you want to really be
super picky and this is already like
stuck with seven picking you may want to
start with the move g5 only because
after g5 but white is exactly one move
bishop g3 when I play Bishop takes
Knight here he has the option of maybe
interpolating the move Bishop takes f6
which can become a little messy and
again I'm not I have to tell you that
this is it looking it's like both line
looks so funny for white the talent will
be delve into the possibilities I mean I
didn't understand for example why you
cannot take this pawn would check and
then take this bishop but I suppose it's
because he's gonna lose the pawn on c5
the long story short g5 would have been
even more clean but okay this is also
good I have to say that Knight Bishop
takes f6 I can just take back on f6 and
after you take here I play c4 so if you
demonstrate let's say I'll show you the
line let's say here Queen takes
something takes here let's say Queen I
suppose because pawn takes looks even
more ridiculous c4 and again you can
probably tell right away that in this
position black is gonna be pretty happy
he can castle and it's going to be not
that easy to attack it's gonna take a
lot of moves I'm on the other hand gonna
play b5 in just one move in one second
and I can just my pieces can just swarm
out like Knight here Bishop out looks to
the files you can just see by by looking
at it optically that block is first but
in the
it was also first so I'm not saying that
yeah it just didn't things didn't work
out so he took with a queen g5 as
promised and the bishop goes to g3 okay
until now I don't think that anybody
played moves as you say oh my goodness
could never do it myself now he plays
Sita XD for that is a very tough move to
make mainly because you think yourself
Wow are you really giving yourself such
an isolated pawn in the center and
you're activating the Queen I mean in
you feel like maybe c4 here also makes
sense but now it doesn't make sense
because you already created the weakness
on the Kings side you left me with the
strong bishop so I can bring my Bishop
to e5 it's a moment I can play h4 and f4
and some moments here why definitely has
his King side counter play so c4 here
would be inaccurate however C takes d4
does several good things at once this is
why this middle game is so important to
learn this game is so important yes
positionally it's a bankrupt move if I
go to some ending I'm going to lose but
black says there's not going to be an
ending I'm going after your King and I'm
gonna hunt it well and boy does he and
the point is this move gains time very
quick development and it opens the file
right opposite the king those are its
benefits okay so he takes Queen takes
hey reasonable I think and he plays
knight c6 now already white is on the
critical list it's amazing the game just
started let's move 11 and already he has
to be he's walking on eggshells what
should he do
in the game he went Queen a4 you'll see
that this move doesn't exactly impress
but it looks like a most natural move it
stops the Queen from coming to a5 with
an immediate tempo an attack it pins the
knight which in many variations is
important because the rook comes to see
it super fast so it's nice that the
knight is that this pin for a little bit
so it has some redeeming values however
probably the most accurate idea would
have been to play Queen III check a very
nice little check and after let's say
Bishop e6 blocking [ __ ]
Queen a3 again the Queen achieved
several points doesn't allow the Queen
to come to a5 so easily and maybe if
black had ideas of counseling and
bringing the reserve later on I'm not
quite letting him
needless to say that black wouldn't be
sitting idle what he would do he would
put his Queen on b6 then played the move
Knight b4 so maybe I should just show
you the idea so let's do it anyways I'll
show the moves it's worth it so we have
this and we have this and I'm suggesting
this and I'm thinking that again my next
move is probably going to be Knight to
before shutting the Queen and it's
diagonal and then I'll be able to cast
also be able to put a rock on the C file
and the white position is just very very
very groggy okay however you'll see that
it got even worse Queen a4 Queen went to
a4 and again there are many tempting
moves you think whoa should i cancel
first should I go Bishop d7 and pretend
that I have a Sudan Knight move that's
gonna move somewhere but Vinick will
have none of that with great precision
he plays Bishop f5 excellent excellent
this move is just I don't know I think
that probably by now Kara's also
realized that something have gone south
but in great speed because again all you
have to do is that if you are too
consumed with what I said so far you can
even look away for a second I didn't
sometimes look back at the board and I'm
like wait a minute the White King
canceled the blocking didn't cancel but
the black King looks completely safe
there are not no checks nothing and I
can easily save it the White King
however is sitting in an open file I'm
nearly still mated they have exactly one
move to make if I want to go and that
means out and don't laugh at this move
because in a second you'll see that that
would have been the best escape for Y so
this is really trouble City this is a
lot of trouble okay III again who can
blame you for this move I think this is
the only move the computer of course
agrees he needs to develop his bishop
and he's really hoping to go here
however you'll see that that's just not
enough once again it spot vinick's
movement again what to do castle first
or do what
he says well let me do what I know that
I want to do for sure I don't know if I
want to play King f8 I don't know if I
want to castle but I do know that I want
to work on the C file which is an open
file right opposite the King again
looking in the position just by looking
at it even if you are a beginner I think
if I show this to a beginners class
they'll say just looking at it you can
tell that black is very very much in
command from White's point of view you
can only say one thing winter is coming
and it's gonna be very painful
so again hard to suggest what to do in
the game he went Bishop d3 the natural
move I don't know what else could have
done I think that the only move that
probably prolongs the game but again
there is no way in the world you can
make this move against Botvinnik Pence
and survive I don't think you're right
against me and survive is King veto
that's the move that was recommended I
think by the computer after some
churning if you have to make this move
here what can I say this is it's not
gonna it's not gonna be good this is not
gonna be good the king is in the middle
of the board with bad development and
all the black pieces are developed in
one second I will castle all I need to
do is add my queen I can do it with a
freebie like Queen b6
tickle-tickle and you know at some point
d4 will become a factor 94 is gonna
become a factor you're not done moving
your king and your pieces are not
developed there's no coordination
whatsoever there's no hope at the higher
level there's no hope there's just no
way somebody if you put stock fish
against Carlsen and Cranston has white
he's gonna get zero out of ten no chance
so hard to believe that this is of
course it's also up psychologically are
very tough move to make so he played
Bishop to d3
again it looks like in this position
you'd say well I mean I can do anything
and be better now you still have to be
utterly accurate that's why this middle
game is so important it's like okay what
can I do the bishop is attacking my
bishop I can trade immediately I can
move my king and pretend that Ivan and
my check somewhere can I afford to do
that I can move my bishop away from the
diagonal I can protect it whatever
there's only one move and he played it
of course Queen d7
I didn't say it was an impossible to
figure out maybe some of you already did
but this is the only move to really do
it properly
he kills two birds with one stone he
defends the bishop on f5 and he is
threatening a disaster with the knight
now so now that the knight is no longer
pinned and the rook is here I just want
to move for example might be 495 but
some might move that's just gonna really
really hurt so Karis reluctantly moves
away from the file that was his plan
the idea of Bishop d3 is to play King V
one without the bishop controlling the
evil diagonal however he went from one
pitfall to another now black has this
already game over by doing don't think
for a second that this is this is just
completely decisive I think the computer
has sensed this position as if black was
up more than a piece which is quite a
lot so actually with the neck in the
next comment you're probably going to
smile at what I'm gonna say so but when
he continues mercilessly Bishop takes d3
check and you know things are bad when
the computers first choices to go King
a1 you know if I have to just he took my
piece and I can't even afford to retake
I have to go King I want yeah something
went really really really not so good
with this game yeah I said necessity but
okay in real game a human of course will
take otherwise you could just resign and
again but the NIC makes an obvious move
but a tricky one again you attempted to
think whoa weekly system the last string
this Knight and rookie I haven't been
developed yet my rook is dying to get
here can I do something with the knight
again the answer is no if you move the
knight there is no check or threatened
threat of mate I'll trade Queens I don't
think you really want to do that so he
once again voluntarily pins his knight
but understanding that the attack on the
rook is very more important yeah this is
this is a very very tough now it's time
for white to start gives to give
something to the community because he
was a bad boy right something went wrong
if he goes Queen dee one night before is
just the end of the world so he must
play he for he must create some sort of
a an interference with
queen of course black is not going to
take you with the Queen allowing a trade
of Queens because then down the pawn
black can play another thirty moves here
that game did not last thirty moves so
how to take back again I guess you know
many many good ways to do it he simply
took with the night if you take with the
pawn then I have two choices after
taking the pawn I could play maybe rooks
III contest the follow route d1 just
defend my first rank and again I'm not
saying that this is a pretty picture for
white but it's complete haven't compared
to what is about to happen
so Knight takes again I've more threats
than you can imagine
I mean I'm threatening everything I'm
1395 I'm threatening not all kinds of
thing Knight takes Bishop on on g3 for
example nine takes F - I'm threatening
the world so king a1 and necessity again
a forced move according to the computer
if you go queen d1 again night before
for example is or might c5 and just
winning the pinning and winning so king
a1 and again what to do in this position
in the first inclination is maybe to
play Knight c5 forking the Queen in the
rock however I still have a check here I
don't think he's gonna save the game in
the long run but again but Vinick is a
big believer in in maximum chest and I'm
also a very big proponent of it I say in
in regular chess
always go for the maximum there's no
overkill in chess if you have a way to
win a rock or a piece and exactly equal
terms do you have to make no compromise
I expect to win the rock if you have
made into or winning the Queen I expect
the mate so and that's a very good
attitude because that that means that
you never just oh I see a good move when
I play it it means I see a good move all
right let me see what's the best that I
can I can be offered I always go for the
best deal so castles what a surprise
I'll move eighteen all of a sudden he
decides he wants to cancel and the
reason is completely single-minded he
wants to be able to move this horse
that's it
right now it's pinned and that's
annoying I don't want to start
calculating Knight moves and checks and
King f8 and all that that's all nonsense
I Castle
and the floodgates are open now there is
just no defense nothing
you know before if you would have taken
nine takes Bishop I would just take back
9f2 I might have played rook f3 always a
move but now there is just no move now
there is just no hope I don't want to
win a pawn or just go on some phantom
attack now there's just no hope okay in
the game he went rook to d1 what else
there's really nothing else Knight c5 is
now a big threat winning a rock and okay
so I can't blame him so he went here and
once again there are several choices I
have to say that here there's more than
one winning move from blacks point of
view but again he plays so accurately so
beautifully that really every time y
thinks maybe I can just giving you
something a pawn and maybe I can play on
maybe we can go to some end game you see
what bottleneck is just rootless like a
hyena and again what do you think the
best move is here just like by maybe
even more by intuition than anything
else I mean it's just think about this
move I'm gonna play and I'm gonna let
you guess because this is more like a
recorded show so think of what move
you're gonna play here again intuitively
because we don't I don't give you enough
time it's otherwise that maybe you were
to figure out and bam the best
absolutely the best the problem is that
the Queen has no good moves in this
position simply no relief he tried to
take it okay if you don't take it then
where are you going Queen c2 night b4 is
no relief no nerves no safety at all
yeah I just don't know just there's
nothing to suggest so he took it as good
as any Knight to d4 now we understand
the pawn sacrifice the other night goes
into the game with vengeance Queen d3
trying to have some say along the
diagonal because of course black was
just threatening to for example take the
bishop and then give smothered mate how
many of you have seen smothered made
before some of you most of you okay
so in this position he plays Knight C to
check luring the King into the diagonal
and now he says okay the only thing that
stands between me and my queen on the
diagonal is my opponent's Queen let's
force it out of it and in this position
looking at the position he realized that
he's about to lose everything literally
everything I mean he's going to get made
it and lose everything and he resigned
there's just no no move at all he's
about to lose his Queen and the Queen
can't afford to leave the diagonal
because then my knight here is going to
start making some moves so complete
disaster just complete an utter disaster
so if to some again - this is kind of a
game that probably is not a bad idea to
see again and again so if you see it
again on YouTube that's advisable but
again if to start from this position
yeah castling such an optimistic move
who would have believed that the player
at this level would just not so
underestimate the strength of what the
storm that is coming in front of his
King so we saw what is the plan again we
said g5 might be a little cleaner but
okay we get to the same kind of position
g5 and take some d4 again sometimes
again another lesson from this middle
game that I'm hoping that you pick up
that when you have chances to attack
when you see that the king is in danger
is an unsafe position forget about
everything put aside everything you
learned about positional chest you can
make a weakness on the King side you can
give a bishop for a night for no reason
in an open position in a very open
position you can give yourself an
isolated pawn and say forget about the
pawn structure completely all because
everything comes with time the gain of
time and opening lines is way way way
more important completely outweighs the
pawn structure and as we saw I mean the
game just played itself all the pieces
got into the game very quickly and it
was just very very embarrassing winning
material and the final straw b5 really a
very very strong move completely
discombobulating the Queen so
you can play either night before or 94
you know like if the Queen went to a3
for example he would have played 94 with
the IDF night c2 of course the rook
cannot take it because it's made and
again if you can see the reason never
forget to develop your pieces there's
just I don't care how excuse me how
cliched that might sound or how silly it
may sound but you really really have to
follow the principle to some degree but
if this night was out even in oblivion
like here then half of those problems
would have been gone however no and game
over it's not every day that somebody at
the level of Karis loses in 22 moves
with the white pieces very very
impressive the player with the white
pieces I think I'm sure another game of
his this this trip I don't have to
disclose his name is Vasi appeared and
here's again one of the stronger
grandmasters in the former Yugoslavia in
the first part of the 20th century and
of course some of you might know the
piers defense efore d6 d4 Knight f6
named after him and the player with the
black pieces left needs even less
introduction the world champion former
world champion Alexander Alekhine your
king like I like to say it and I really
enjoy showing lots of his games
I find myself that every year I show at
least four or five of his games
sometimes I even find a game that I
haven't seen before I haven't seen in a
long time and it's really it's really
nice what he did in this game was really
very impressive again remember he's not
playing in a Simon against NN or amateur
he is playing a strong Grandmaster in in
a torah in a strong international
tournament so again a d4 opening d4 d5
c4 e6 93 c5 alright so we know that the
former world champion had many strengths
strengths he was extremely original very
original player he was very creative and
had a lot of imagination and definitely
not lacking confidence however opening
is wise I wouldn't say that he was
exemplary to say the least
so his openings many times are kind of
funny sometimes he finally makes the
Mets finally make mistakes even as early
as moved to
three ready it's really funny of course
I have the benefit of 70 years and lots
of lots of stuff to to prove it
okay this of course is just a terrorist
defense it's nothing wrong with it and
he plays here again a gambit which is
not very common but it's a playable
gambit okay always taking the bull by
its horns bull by his horns really
trying to cause the most confusion right
out of the open I'm applying a normal
line so now the idea is very simple if
white takes the pawn immediately black
is gonna play knight c6 a free
developing move based on the fact that
if pawn takes the Queen is hanging the
Queen will have to redraw then is going
to regain his pawn which threatens to
advance and in the case that you take it
I'm going to keep developing my pieces
so it's a it's a very interesting pawn
sacrifice I think it's called the Shara
Henning variation or something like that
but in any event this is not really a
topic the idea is the middlegame of
course so to avoid that he plays check
again a little nuance in the opening
pretty much forcing Bishop d7 and now it
takes on d4 so the move knight c6 which
attacks the Queen with the tempo and
threatens after the pawn capture to push
the pawn is no longer there okay so of
course you must take I mean if I get the
pawn to d6 that might become a little
annoying right so takes and Queen takes
again very logical so far knight c6 very
nice Bishop g5 okay so far it's okay
9 f6 and Queen d2 the queen of course
was now under attack h6 Bishop takes
yeah we have some if you could see
there's some resemblance between this
position and the other I mean there's
some not really the whole position of
course but some elements are the same
and again the question is should we take
the bishop should we take Bishop takes
Knight I think that again it's a
over-optimism to take this knife I think
that Bishop H for maintaining the pin
now it's not so easy to play g4 g5
bishop g3 I mean you could do it but
it's not
not as scary than the other game so you
took takes black is lacking a little bit
in development and white is thinking
what is my best way to punish it
of course there really isn't because
everything is relatively under control I
mean black is gonna have a really really
good game I'm about to go Bishop before
I want to bring my book to the d8 square
I want to cast or quickly and show that
they have something for my pawn in the
meantime my queen is looking at this
diagonal very hungry D and I'm also kind
of looking at this pawn in some
variations so after some thinking Pearce
played III logical move I think the
queen is defending f2 and you're about
to develop a piece castles okay very
very ambitious and I think that this
kind of through peers offers off his
game here he was really really confused
what to do in this position and I think
that's probably the best move in the
game he played on unbelievable castles I
think that the right move now would have
been Knight to d5 right here
hey don't commit your king and B now you
can play after the Queen is hit after
the Queen moves I might play 92 and
night to see three maybe even would be
four and kind of anchor a knight on d5
completely pacifying the D file that
would have been a smart decision but
again as a grandmaster he goes for this
line but I think again that this line
was based on somewhat a miscalculation
in the middle game he just didn't
appreciate at least one little factor
that's coming his way so if I'm going to
say winter is coming it's true again so
what to do at first you think that white
is very happy he is upper pawn
he is cancelled just like black did on
the same wing with the same open C file
and open D file he might be one move
behind in development but doesn't look
so tragic you think that he'll be able
to at least get the moves nine of three
Bishop out and consolidate after which
is going to be really in good shape okay
so are you looking definitely analyze
for the other question
Bishop g4 that of course had to be
calculated and not very very difficult
and of course pH saw it I mean there's
no he's gonna miss someone mover that's
not a surprise and of course you
prepared something but you completely
underestimated the continuation and that
is what's really nice about this again
you have a middle game where you
sacrifice the pawn you have to
completely development still but how you
still go for it you move a piece twice
you have to justify it of course white
there's one move I can't move my queen
I'm just gonna lose a rock so 1985 and
I'm sure that in this position Pierce
was very happy because now the knight is
well protected he's protected several
times and maybe he even envisioned
something like Queen moves f3 Bishop
moves
efore Bishop c4 maybe even if he wants
to and and how bad can this meet again
he he seemed seemingly he managed to
somehow block that file Denis file how
embarrassing it was to see that he was
wrong but again I think that when you
look at it with a hindsight of seeing
this game it seems really simple because
look at the White King side they're all
spectating when that happens you can
allow that you can afford to do things
that normally you'd be hesitant to do so
step one rook takes d5 tremendous okay
here's the tape maybe he brought yeah I
mean I'm guessing he saw this as well
and he thought okay after Bishop d1
Queen takes do you want I'm not gonna
have it's not gonna be the end of the
world after all we have traded some
pieces and I'm still up upon but they
moved if he must've missed this is I'm
pretty certain I can I mean they're both
not with us anymore so you can ask him
but I'm pretty certain that he missed
that was do you have an idea for a move
don't say it if you have it because it's
really aesthetic I mean like take a look
and think yourself okay now you down in
exchange for an exchange in the pawn
basically you down a piece right now and
yeah maybe you're a little more
developed again the development
advantages there you can always regain
your material some of your material but
that's not what you're into
you don't want to just trade pieces we
already said that so hard to do it your
first instinct is of course which piece
to move let's try to get there I don't
think this is very hard I'm pretty sure
you're not gonna waste time with your
King right now it's a chronic cough Lee
where is you kidding you really can't
afford to move the night right I mean
I'm just gonna give you a check
somewhere and I'm gonna always
consolidate this Bishop is in maximum
capacity if I'm not gonna take the rook
I'm definitely not gonna move it and
again the question is do I have a very
amazing Queen move answer now the Queen
can be in any better position than in
right that it is right now I'm pretty
sure nobody is thinking about moving a
rock right now that's very easy
everybody's laughing and by process of
relatively simple in elimination we
arrived at this Bishop needs to move and
now we're - I have one two three four
five legal moves I I can't go here I'm
gonna lose it I can't go here I'm gonna
lose it with no purpose so it's now one
two three now you have to think yourself
which is the one with the most effect
than me the biggest threat and if you
can make it work it's gonna work
so Bishop III I see a lot of eyebrows
growing up I like that that's good that
means it was a little unexpected well
why is this so good the reason is again
when attacking when you have the
initiative when you're better
development the element of time is more
important than material especially when
every move that loses the material gives
you new avenues for newly found ways to
attack the threat is only queen bee to
mate so what to do in the game I think
he want Queen b3 but let's check some of
the variations for example and again I
have to tell you parenthetically
something that I said in my classes
before those games were analyzed years
ago many many years ago I don't know if
close to the time it was played but
definitely before very strong computers
came to light
so those computer are now like making
all kinds of funny noises at the
commentary and I'm gonna do two because
I look to the computer so should you
take this okay for some unknown reason
the commentator decided to play Queen C
3 track which is not a good idea
because Quincy three king b1 Luke d8
looking decisive but I can afford to
play rook c1 and the computer says equal
that's not a good idea so let's
substitute it with queen a1 check which
is very very strong and again I honestly
don't know what to do king the Queen the
king to d2 loses the rook and the Queen
in one shot so I'm voting for this and
now everything with a tempo takes Queen
takes takes with a tempo if you enter
the default I'm going to visit with my
rook so you have to do to see three or
c1 they're just about the same that's
good to see one because it seems
slightly more sane to go backwards them
on a trip right and now it takes here
and Ruby d8 well you can look for
yourself you want to be white here this
is this is a mother kiss dream actual if
you want to be wiping yeah I mean the
rook is attacking the Queen I have more
checks I have night before at leisure
this is just completely out completely
out out out just horrible position so
and I don't even know if I played the
best line but I know the computer says
this is like plus a million so okay so
taking the bishop is out alternatively
what if I played something like this for
example which now I'm pretending to save
my rook and save the pawn on b2 so you
can't play Bishop things d1 and you
can't make me
so takes takes check here check here
rook here yeah
catastrophe again over I suppose of
Queen takes f1 is also not a bad move to
make you so again this is this plus big
so in the game like I said he played
Queen b3 not exactly like this move is
gonna save him sorry and Bishop takes d1
now it's a very good time to take
because my bishop is developed it
basically what happened is it's almost
like you've got two moves in this
position if I play Bishop in this
position
if a playbill should be one Queen d1
okay but in the image to play this and
this and now Bishop d1 so I'm going to
develop the Bishop of play play Bishop
v1 at once Queen takes d1 Queen takes b2
is made not idea if you play King takes
d1
I can play Bishop takes B - not only did
I regain my pawn but I'm attacking the
f2 pawn I'm threatening rook da check
your king is alone your king side hasn't
been developed it's not good so he tries
to take here so Queen takes f2 again a
very very strong shot regaining the
material if you take my bishop I'm going
to take your Bishop your pawn and you
rock in sequence so Queen d3 the best
defense again he's trying his best to
hold things together now Bishop g4 was
played and the commentators give it an
exclamation mark but the computer says
that Bishop a4 is even more winning this
is very very very strong because after
Bishop if just rook d8 is coming as well
and very bad news
so Bishop g4 but this is also hopeless
9 f3 again it's just hard to find them
with rook the ache is coming followed by
rook V 1 and then night before and it's
all over
so another three takes check of course
if you take I just take on f3 now up
material and calling all the shots so he
was counting of course on this
in-between move Queen check going here
takes okay check everything is
calculated now you can choose between
two unpleasantries one is to play Queen
to d1 then black will play Queen takes
III check winning material and again the
rook and the night are coming to
participate very very shortly this is
just an easily technically one game in
the game he decided to play King cking
c2 trying to maintain some practical
chances but after rook c8 again he must
realize that life is not that good
very very miserable so he tried Queens
III check okay check of course notice
that this was a fork I'm attacking the
king and the Queen if you thought that
the queen is to take immediately the
answer is no because I have my own check
and the road gives a check King b3 queen
d1 check King a3 rooks e5 doesn't look
good again notice just like in the
previous game how there are two pieces
on the King side that are just not
playing you cannot I mean doesn't matter
what what material you're up when you
count the material right now you're done
a rook and a bishop for all means and
purposes if you manage to develop
everything andropause my attack then
okay you can prove that they exist but
right now you're done material and down
the King so ok again many many
variations that we mention a few
in case of b4 check mate
if b3 of course the threat is to go or
okay five check if b3 to try to hide
them check King out check mate
depressing so he tried King before but
you can probably imagine where the Queen
and rook and Knight on the board when
the King starts going this way he's
basically about to make a little circle
back to e1 for the next game
so not pleasant Queen d2 check King
takes rook okay I guess maybe by now you
already saw the ending but just decided
to make it like a beautiful finish if he
goes king a3 there's gonna be a check on
a5 so or King b3 check on d1 this is
mate any which way you look at it he
took b6 and checkmate on the board again
if you look in this position I'm really
excited by all those red colours and the
Queen on a5 and the King made it but if
you ask what is the story of the game
once again I'll point at the rook and h1
in the bishop on f1 you cannot play
chess with half your pieces that's the
price that you pay so once again from a
very good development advantage
you saw a brilliant middle game really a
good performance by a strong player
knowing where to put the pieces playing
fearlessly and basically with one target
the guy with the target the king
so both games at one common denominator
a castle King Queen side they just went
completely blue ok guys this was it I
hope you enjoyed the mill game lecture
try to develop your pieces and castle
good idea